all right uh well thank you guys so much
for having me um uh hello from sunny
California uh I'm really excited to be
able to come and talk with you remotely
about some uh work that happened
regarding Dynamic interactions um so
we're basically taking quto documents
that you know and love and that you saw
a lot of really great features get
developed for and we're allowing them to
become a lot more interactive using
LeBar so before we begin though um few
quick things uh there's a lot of thank
yous that go out uh first to the core
developers of webar um itself so George
and Lionel have been absolutely great uh
the second part is thank you so much to
the testers um so uh Ellie Holmes and
Bob rutus gave some really great
feedback before uh the extension was
released and then um in terms of uh
contributors uh we've had uh Joe Yun or
Joe Yung apologies in advance um work on
some accessibility and then thank you
again to the entire quto team just not
only for the product but for you know uh
answering my questions and GitHub issues
and uh discussion form posts so thank
you so much um with that in mind uh a
lot of the talk is GNA sort of focus
here on the main motivation for why
Dynamic documents are really great and
that sort of goes with this entire
notion of uh setting up an R environment
and how it's not really fun um it'll
then sort of uh move towards looking at
the different Technologies that'll uh
allow this environment set up to be a
lot easier and sort of create uh every
day as like a a day one kind of
experience uh for
students uh and then we're going to sort
of pivot more to how this can be used
inside of education so how you can
inform your teaching and we'll also talk
just a little just super super small
amount on how you can actually use web R
um uh within a research setting it's
still really early on um but there's a a
lot of really exciting things and uh
we'll sort of touch base on some of
those perhaps future uh ideas in the
unlocking new possibilities part at the
end so that being said um let's talk a
little bit about r environment setup and
the motivating case here was the course
that I got a chance to design almost 10
years ago now uh called stat 385 at the
University of Illinois uh back in the
day uh I sort of thought students uh
would have access to a computer um in
which they can install software uh it
seemed like a very reasonable uh
expectation and then the Computing
Paradigm changed we had tablets enter uh
the market and we had Chromebooks enter
the market so we had all of these
systems that sort of
required um uh webbased interfaces to
sort of have students actually
experience
material so that sort of brings us to
that little devil part but uh that's
just one small downside if we take a
traditional um student that has a laptop
there's usually three steps uh that the
student has to do uh before the first
day of class uh the first one is they
have to be able to pick out their
operating system so Windows Mac or Linux
the second part is they have to follow
the appropriate R installation uh recipe
and then the third of course is to
install our studio so these three
together it's not that bad
maybe but when you start to add in other
parts like if you need developer tools
so if you're having students explore
compiled code well then that opens an
entire new uh level of difficulties as
well so our tools itself is notorious
for changing the installer and on Mac
well uh there's more of a community run
installer effort um where uh the compile
tool chain can easily be set up so
students usually at this point are
asking well why can't I just go to app
store and just press the install button
why do I have to go through an
installer so it's it's one of these real
sticking points uh when you're bu uh
trying to start up a course so the day
one class as a result sort of goes a
little bit like this first you have that
wonderful student that says how do we
install R in our studio so they didn't
get your email or they didn't have a
chance to install it the second second
student when they try and run your code
well they say it doesn't work um this
could be because they didn't update our
they didn't update our studio or they
didn't put the script in the right spot
another student could just even be uh
using a company computer right so they
don't even have permissions to install
anything and then lastly um uh the
student has a really new Macbook and
some software doesn't really install
appropriately on it so there's so many
issues with that day one you know uh
starting place to actually have people
explore data so if we could reimagine
what actually this day one looks like
we'd want to go off into the cloud so we
want to go towards some kind of cloud
computing because the steps here right
are you would have to log into an
environment you'd have to select a
project and then you'd have to start
exploring these three steps super quick
all done inside of a web
browser but but what if we could drop
one of the steps and when I say drop one
of the steps I mean just gently modify
so instead of having the student find
the project you could just use a badge
so the badge would effectively take you
into the login screen if they're not
already logged in and then you
immediately get them into an environment
that's preset up for you to go off and
explore
this feature of um posit Cloud uh or in
this case our studio Cloud before was
really really appealing and it was an
amazing um thing to
experience however um sometimes it's not
uh really practical to be able to have
students get into our studio Cloud it's
could be that you know they run out of
free compute credits they can't afford
the $5 per month uh live it so on and so
forth so can we figure out a way to sort
of recreate this idea of just having
them click and they immediately get
access to um be able to start exploring
and this sort of comes through with this
technology
breakthrough uh first we have this
really powerful new idea of web assembly
which you can sort of think about it uh
like flash in your browser except way
better or you could think of it like
Java applets which is even way way
better um and then we have web R which
sort of takes huge advantage of this web
assembly technology to allow R to exist
in your browser and then last but not
least we have quto itself so we're going
to really quickly mention why quto is
really useful so quto um basically took
nine or so different R studio um
or um our markdown packages and sort of
unified them uh together so there's a
really great common interface and it
also extended the features that were
possible so when we start to develop uh
extensions to quto you can really easily
switch formats without hassle so we can
just take this HTML document and we can
immediately plug it right into a website
and then we can start serving it's
really really really nice just for that
but as you saw from earlier
presentations there's so many more
wonderful features of so that then
takes us to the next piece of technology
that's really useful instead of having
to go out to uh posst it um Cloud what
we can do is we can use a compute server
or not we can use a compute server but
we can move away from this Paradigm of
needing a compute server where we have
our running on that server and then we
have this linked connection between our
and then the students computer instead
what we can do is we can move over to
just using any kind of web server that
if it can serve a file so that is it can
allow a student to download a file they
have a working copy of R right in their
web browser without sort of us worrying
about it so um this then takes us to
that third huge breakthrough and that is
web R itself so on the left hand side
you can see some rcode where you're sort
of exploring um how to iterate through
items in a list and then on um the right
side you can sort of see the uh same
code that would allow you to work with r
except directly inside of a web browser
so this allows us again to just move
away from really needing a compute
server and just sort of having a server
that that we can use to download files
where if the student has the the file
then um basically they can use R right
in their web browser so it might seem a
little bit complicated so let's sort of
try and show what this unification path
really is um between these three
Technologies so to start we have quto
right inside of our studio next we're
going to go ahead and press that render
button and and lo and behold it's going
to render into an HTML document now
again everything that you're seeing
inside of the blue rectangle that's all
been powered by
so if we move over to that idea of
needing uh sort of like a a web server
what we can do here is we can go out to
any place that sort of serves web
content in a static context so that is
GitHub pages netlify and even cop Pub um
we can immediately place these um sort
of rendered uh HTML documents online
really quick now the next part is we're
using web R itself to have R active
inside of the browser so everything
inside of the purple um rectangle
basically that's all sort of um uh
happening because web R exists um so
where a lot of the dynamic interaction
um with CTO coming in which is uh one of
the huge parts of this talk is really
through a quto extension called quto
webar which basically puts in a way of
taking a code cell and translating it in
such a way that it works uh with web r
instead of needing here to actually
render a document uh just with r itself
so it's a really really powerful uh
ecosystem that you're able to come up
with as a result so what does this then
look like in action well um what we can
do is we can press the Run code button
we can change values so here we switched
from adding to fitting linear model and
now you know we can even in the same
area we could create a plot so there's a
huge level of Versatility to what we can
do and in terms of making this available
uh the web extension or the the quto web
R extension really only needs to be made
available on the person's computer
that's rendering the document so uh that
means that you do need to install a
piece of software uh the easiest way
here is just to go uh on the lower left
hand side of your R Studio window press
the terminal tab which is right next to
your console and then type a quick
install command of quto add coatless
quto dwr uh press enter and you have
like two quick prompts to verify that
you do indeed want to install the
extension so on that end right uh we now
sort of have it installed what we can do
is we can sort of make our existing um
HTML documents inide of CTO Dynamic just
by sort of changing four things the
first part that we have to change is we
have to modify um the documents yaml to
incorporate an engine parameter so if we
say engine Knitter this makes sure that
all of the code cells are going to be
run uh using Knitter as the compute
engine the alternative here is
everything would go through Jupiter
um which would require you to install
more software from there we need to add
a filter this filter again is that quto
extension um allowing us to incorporate
web R and then the third part here is we
switch the code cell type from R to web
r-r so once those three are done we can
just render the document and lo and
behold we get an Interactive document
that we can use just about anywhere that
there's uh a static web server host um
to share our content and have students
learn so there's other parts to this as
well uh again there's a lot of different
options you can modify web ours uh
options you can even change the
extension options uh yourself there's a
bunch of customization options um one of
the huge Parts here that I'll just point
out is you really can um uh improve the
user experience if you uh put up at the
top of your document the kinds of
packages that are required uh because
that sort of allows the document to load
with all of your software available um
in comparison to just having them
interactively install uh a package for
each code cell that's needed so there's
again a lot of options that you have
feel free to check out um the quto um
Web Bar uh extension documentation uh
online now the other part here uh really
quick is the context so context allows
us to basically have uh Bas the this
level of interactivity so we can run
code we can also create an output right
so output only and then we have a setup
and the setup is largely um left empty
so um when it comes to education these
parts allow us to just have these ready
too exercises so we have the wh if
scenario we have a fill-in-the blank
kind of approach and we can have it work
about anywhere which is really really
powerful there are always limits the
first limit here is this highly uh this
very much so requires uh an internet
connection at the start not all the
packages are
available uh and it's not really a
replacement for DS
code or uh our studio but the other part
that's really useful here is you start
to actually see um student Behavior Uh
like never before so we can actually see
how students are going through and
learning uh from the document just by
adding here a short
code uh this also works with books too
uh in quto format so generally students
spent about 1.5 times more on Dynamic
documents um uh they frequently
interacted with code cells where the
outcome wasn't immediately clear in
their mind and they really describe this
approach as being more modern um
compared to
oldfashioned so they generally have
liked it quite a bit um in terms of that
research part well research-wise not
necessarily quite uh to the point where
where um uh uh you can really compile
your own uh our package uh that's not on
cran in an easy sense but if it is on
cran um which you should always strive
to put your research on CR um it
actually uh might even be available
right now to inside of webar which means
that you can really quickly take this R
code that you've developed and you can
include a reproducible link to your um
quto notebook alongside of the paper no
longer do you need this static file um
now there's a few new possibilities as
well one of the huge things here is
reveal JS that's a little bit
problematic we do need to improve the
interface and then lastly uh we want to
sort of also explore a little bit with
pyoid so here you can sort of see a
quick pyoid demo uh which basically
allows us to run um python as well
there's a lot more um if you are
interested again there's some really
great web uh uh resources the extension
the project and the community overall
for webar is really growing rapidly and
we'd love to have you here with us so
thank you so much I'm sorry if I went
over um if there's any questions I'm
more than happy to take them now or uh
feel free to reach out and just contact
me with
[Music]
them lovely thank you can you hear
me excellent I'm going to ask you one
question because people um um are
impressed and thinking about starting to
convert to stuff so the obvious question
is how stable would you say that quarter
War web bar extension API
is um so I would say as long as you're
not trying to do um any kind of direct
um changes to the Web Bar um instance
that we have you should be fine um so I
would say we're not planning on really
changing that context option um there's
only really one one kind of component
that you have uh and that is really that
context option um uh that that that
could potentially change at this point
uh we will upgrade um the extension as
new versions of R and web R become
available so that part is just the part
of the natural process I can't guarantee
you know it would you're what you're
changing would break or not break
chances are the code that you're running
it it should be fine um is is my hope um
and because of how this is done each
extension version uh it's basically um
locked so as long as you don't update
the extension again I think you should
be fine well that's great um I'm going
to stop here cuz we are a time so um
please join me in thanking all of the
speakers
[Music]
your